erdöl wird knapper und ein
millionenschwerer fußballstar hat die
lösung für das problem gefunden klicks
um science-fiction das forschungs
resultat könnte 20 milliarden dollar
wert sein mathieu flamini ist dem ein
oder anderen von euch vielleicht als mit
profi bekannt
wer von euch aber wusste dass sich der
millionenschwere star auch für die
wissenschaft interessiert und sich
direkt mit seiner eigenen firma an der
forschung beteiligt bis vor kurzem hat
kaum einer davon auch nur einen blassen
schimmer nicht mal flamini es eltern
wussten von seinem wissenschaftlichen
engagement der sun hatte der zeitung sun
verriet mathieu flamini jetzt so einiges
was bis dato nicht mal seine mitspieler
wussten zitat meine teamkollegen in
mailand wissen es vermutlich seit
letzter woche durch die offizielle
ankündigung meines kollegen erfahren ist
wohl durch diesen artikel so flamini
diese verschwiegenheit bzw geheimhaltung
kann man allerdings durchaus verstehen
die forschungsergebnisse die seiner
firma jetzt gelungen sind eben könnten
vielleicht sogar mehr als 20 milliarden
dollar wert sein chef bei chemicals so
heiß familienfirma hat einen weg
gefunden der wohl in säure in massen zu
produzieren der folien säure level in
säure ist farblos kristallin mit drei
bis fünf euro pro kilo äußerst billig
und einer der wenigen stoffe die erdöl
komplett ersetzen könnten
eine erschöpfende ressource die in der
zeit rat zur energie durch verbrennung
zu erzeugen oder auch kunststoffe oder
chemikalien herzustellen ohne die
synthese von dem so kostbaren erdöl wäre
es unmöglich produkte wie beispielsweise
polyvinylchlorid kurz pvc oder in den
stoff polyamid der beispielsweise in
nylonstrumpfhosen steck zu produzieren
neben der großen erdöl produktpalette
würden natürlich auch die meisten autos
auf der strecke bleiben benzin diesel
und so wird aus erdöl gewonnen erdöl ist
einer der wichtigsten rohstoffe hier auf
der erde problem erdöl ist nur begrenzt
verfügbar und nicht zu vergessen
maßgeblich für den klimawandel
verantwortlich
mit der level ihn soll könnte man
allerdings gleiches erreichen wie man
aktuell mit erdöl erreichen airberlin
säure war bisher ein bedeutungsloses
abfallprodukt in der zuckerherstellung
und eine halbe million tonnen lehm
oliven säure wird jährlich
unnötigerweise weggeworfen auf das ganze
jahr und weltweit verteilt ist eine
halbe million tonnen lehm olin säure
einfach nicht besonders viel
da kommt aber jetzt flamini us firma ins
spiel sie haben es geschafft sowohl in
säure als hauptprodukt nicht nur als
nebenprodukt herzustellen zitat wir
haben sieben jahre daran gearbeitet und
etwas geschafft was keinem zuvor
gelungen ist so flamini selbst
angefangen habe es im jahr 2008 familie
traf nahm mailand auf seinen jetzigen
geschäftskollegen pascal granata
zusammen mit ihm zerbrachen sie sich den
kopf zitat wir überlegten wie wir die
probleme lösen könnten und stießen auf
level in säure sagte flamini der sun mit
probleme meinte er die problematiken in
den themengebieten umwelt klimawandel
erderwärmung und so weiter und so kam es
von der idee zur umsetzung mittlerweile
hat gf bei chemicals ein patent auf ira
levin herstellungsmethode aus mais und
essens abfällen und beschäftigt rund 400
mitarbeiter zu der entwickelten methodik
können wir natürlich nicht besonders
viel erzählen da ist einfach noch keine
konkreten verfahrensbeschreibung außer
beispielsweise diese grafik gibt 1 kann
man jedoch sagen dieses vom platini in
die wissenschaft in die forschung
investierte geld ist wahrscheinlich
nicht falsch angelegt was sagt ihr zu
dem engagement des fußball-stars lasst
uns eure meinung da und nicht vergessen
clixoom für mehr spannende videos zu
abonnieren und das nächste video
natürlich gucken bis dann bleibt dran